an event was held in boulder city today
to recognize america's veterans who've
passed
the woman who organized it flew across
the country to start what she calls a
necessary tradition
sasha loftis joining us now live from
southern nevada veterans memorial
cemetery with the story
denise and brian the organizers of
today's event brought honor to our
country's veterans in such a beautiful
way
you can see the flags behind me are in
front of 1440
different gravestones all to remember
those we have loved
and lost
[Music]
a touching tribute for a lifetime of
sacrifice
these are veterans you know dead or
alive veterans day
you know is for them so we want to make
sure that they are honored
with each carefully placed flag and
powerful salute
those here in boulder city pay their
respects
to those who served our country i've
started a great thing to honor veterans
and i feel like a very proud mom right
now to see all these people out here
dawn kramer traveled from michigan to
hold this veterans day ceremony
wednesday
god we remember and we grieve the idea
first formed in 2019
when she came to visit her late father's
grave and realized
nothing was done to honor those we've
lost
last year when i was here there wasn't
anyone here and there were no flags and
now i look around and i see a bunch of
marine flags
see our american flag so she made it her
mission to work with local organizations
and give these patriots the recognition
they deserve
i'm respecting each and every one of
these men and we had so much outpouring
from the community
she hopes these efforts will act as a
symbol of her gratitude
for many years to come thank you for
going through everything that you went
through for all of us
with all my heart i thank you
don says she hopes to make this event a
yearly tradition from here on out
she and the local organizations that
helped organize this
hope to place a flag at every single
gravestone at this cemetery next year
that adds up to just under 39 000. for
now reporting live in boulder city sasha
loftis
8 news now